it was supposed to be the jewel in
Britain's manufacturing Crown our first
home-grown gigafactory co-financed by
the government turning out electric car
batteries from its plant in the
Northeast allowing this country to
compete with the rest of the world but
when British fault collapsed into
Administration earlier this year the
dream was left in tatters now in his
first TV interview since its implosion
the company's co-founder has told Sky
News that the government and
specifically Rishi sunak must take much
of the blame when you think of what
might have been do you feel
do you feel sad do you feel angry
devastated
we shed Blood Sweat and Tears into this
team was so passionate
we had one window of opportunity
to build a gigafactory and have that
ready by 25. instead we lost that window
of opportunity now we're two years
delayed earliest earliest we can build a
gigafactor by 27.
imagine we already
are behind East Asia we're already
behind Continental Europe
UK unfortunately has lost out or is
losing out on the gigafactory economy
which is massive in terms of job
creation but unfortunately didn't see
that same support
from the conservative government in
order to level up the Northeast
because Northeast wasn't as important
for them
as maybe other places in this country
you didn't get the support that you felt
you should have got definitely not
at least not from a timing perspective
and who was Chancellor at that point
it was a major rivalry going on between
Mr Johnson and Mrs at that period of
time but if you're looking back at the
one thing that I think they could have
swung out I think Bridgeport was
collateral damage stuck between a rock
and a hard place between Johnson
University sooner the Rivalry between 10
and 11. yes and do you think this has
done damage to you know the hopes of
others who want to build these factories
in the UK unless UK changes his
industrial strategy
we will keep losing out on large-scale
projects arrival left the electric mini
left it's not just British Vault there's
a clear lack of industrial strategy if
people maybe have read some of the
stories about British Vault over the
past few months they might have seen
stories about you know big spending many
millions of pounds being spent on
Executive salaries about a big mansion
that was that was hired for executives
with a swimming pool about a yoga
instructor as well I mean it seems like
when you put all of that together it
does seem like quite excessive doesn't
it so absolutely right
taking and breaking them down one by one
I think is very important
having a wellness instructor has a
preventative measure for People's Health
that is economical to be able to do that
virtually for 300 people at a low cost
of roughly two three thousand pounds a
month that is very economical when you
say Mansion for millions that was rented
for approximately a hundred thousand
pounds a year the concern I think some
people within government and many I
imagine in the public have is just that
you were asking for quite a lot of
public money so taxpayers money
and there are concerns that not all of
that money would have been spent in as
disciplined away
as they would have liked do you think
that's fair there was no
misappropriation of fund because not a
single penny was spent on a private jet
100 000 went to a as you say a mansion
well it was a large house and if you
look at the cost of renting a hotel room
for that many people during that period
of time it was far more economical to
rent a house the fact that it happened
to have a pool that wasn't working for
18 months by the way it has nothing to
do with it
a government spokesperson said taxpayer
money must always be used responsibly
which is why full due diligence was
undertaken before a final Grant offer
was made the government remains
committed to leveling up across the UK
and is actively engaging with companies
to secure Investments that will ensure
the UK remains a world leader in
automotive Manufacturing but the
allegations come amid a growing sense
that the UK may have squandered a chance
to create a battery industry and without
that industry car exports to Europe will
incur more tariffs stalantis owner of
Citron and Peugeot has said it may shut
down its plants here if this or the
brexit deal isn't changed speaking at an
event today the chancellor said watch
this space but without these factories
the fate of Britain's car industry is
increasingly under question
at Conway Sky News